I open the work session for the children
and family law subcommittee that is
going to be considering House Bill
499 the court shall admit any evidence
or testimony in any form which the
respondent believes will be favorable
and 475 the judge shall follow the rules
of evidence in admitting um items into
evidence
uh they're very similar bills so my
thought is to proceed with a general
discussion on Rules of Evidence uh and
then break it out into the two
particular bills um let me start with an
opening remark and um then we'll turn it
over anybody else uh on the work group
who wishes to share just a reminder that
this is a work session not a hearing
therefore um all of the pink cards that
people would like to sign in on are in
my pocket and you don't get one uh we
can occasionally admit someone to answer
a brief and Technical question if we so
desire but it's not a hearing with
people giving evidence we've heard a lot
of evidence and a lot of
testimony
indicating that uh some judges seem to
be w way too broad in their
discretionary powers and in fact um a
wonderful book I it should be on the
best seller list called New Hampshire
Court rules annotated Rules of Evidence
the Chief Justice gave me one of these a
couple months ago and I've read it four
times it's 280 Pages lots of nice
footnotes and cross references and it
makes it abundantly clear that in New
Hampshire in the
uh Circuit Court The Rules of Evidence
in this book um are at the total
discretion of the judge the judge may
choose to honor one of these rules or
not and the book gives the reason why
that is because the judge needs the
discretion to make things in his or her
opinion to be fair and good for everyone
the question question is however does
that take place and according to some
testimony that we've heard some people
believe the judge in his or her case was
way too broad in admitting things other
people indicated the judge was way too
restrictive still other people believed
that the judge was restrictive towards
men but not women and other people
believed it was women not men so the
question
is what should we do about Rules of
Evidence the two bills before us lay
down blanket statements uh telling the
judge exactly what to do uh this is the
case in
Vermont and we have learned that in
Vermont according to their rules rule of
evidence
1101 family cases are not accepted that
the Rules of Evidence apply literally in
Vermont it is totally the opposite the
difficulty comes in that about 80% of
the cases heard in Family Court one or
both litigant are their prosay that is
to say they are representing themselves
they are not
lawyers some of these are very well read
in law most of them are not
and so when something comes up for
example the judge rules a piece of
evidence in and one of the litigants
does not like that many times the
litigant does not know what to do or the
litigant will much later in the trial
say oh I object to that in the Rules of
Evidence in New Hampshire objections
must be made as soon as possible as soon
as the judge allows a piece of evidence
in the other side protesting should say
objection secondly the other side must
give a reason why that piece of evidence
should not be admitted other than just I
don't like it or it hurts my case many
people who are prade do not know that
what to do there are many other places
where uh rules of evidence that a judge
may use may be confusing
or not known to a litigant going
prosay uh the Same by the way is true if
a judge decides not to admit something
into evidence objection must be
immediately made and the reason given in
fact if this does not occur and the
decision of the judge is
appealed that piece of evidence not
admitted cannot be admitted
in an appell at court it's too late or
if you wanted that piece of evidence
stricken and do not object and now it is
in the appell at court it's too late for
that as well so the question here is
what do we do especially when it seems
perhaps a judge is going too far one way
or the other or is tipped into an
imbalance should we like
Vermont just require everything in this
book be done by the judge or should we
keep it as it is now but find a way to
address the concerns that many people
have raised so that's my sort of opening
Salvo I've um pretty much said this
several times to the others with me so
with that I'll shut up and just see who
speak
wrong yes so I I I agree I believe that
we we're on the right concept right now
or the right uh rules of EV evidence uh
however tweaking
something um to balance the scales may
be something we look at uh as far as for
75 um you know it requires all evidence
be
presented uh then it asks for what
evidence is not presented um to be a
reason written um so it sort of
conflicts with what it what it what it
first
sure
Frozen uh yeah so it's sort of conflicts
uh from the beginning where everything
will be presented uh to the starting in
uh the judge needs to write a reason as
to why it wasn't uh
admitted um so I'm not sure
if this is a correct Avenue to make any
fix
representative
Greg thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you all for being here today I know it's
cold in here you know I I'm conflicted
on this um just because when we say
something you know I've known quite a
few people that have had their own court
cases and stuff and it's always hard
whenever we think something's pertinent
whether or not you know the the overseer
of the situation also thinks it's
pertinent because it's all up to
individual you know your own own
perception and
stuff
I I think we would have to think long
and hard before we start to you know
encroach on the judges in a way that the
reason they are in the position they're
in is to be able to you know see things
impartially now in cases where we have
judges and I know that these are not the
norm right these are not the majority of
what we're seeing but the ones that we
are seeing where there's you know a lack
of well we say discretion maybe we have
it looks like moms are getting more
favor or fathers getting more favor
whichever way there are other states
Illinois being one that have um kind of
like a Judicial kind of an oversight
where they do have um almost like when
you're a student teacher you have the
principal kind of come sit in they do
have somebody that comes and sits in and
observes you know we've talked about
this before we've talked about the
recordings being turned on and off and
and all that I also want to be very
cognizant of the fact that when we
discuss how much evidence we're going to
make or you know if we're going to
decide that we're going to tell the
judges to take in all this evidence the
amount of time that that's going to take
I know that there are certainly um
litigants that would love to you know
hold up a case and give months and
months and months of hearsay and all
these other things so um you know saying
that they just have to take all that
evidence and would bog down our already
very busy court system so I just want to
think about those things when we're
thinking about you know making some kind
of legislation or whatever but I do not
think that either one of these um bills
hold uh a best case scenario for our
front well they're thinking of something
uh the five of
us um are this work group in children
and family law because the five of us up
here are also on the special committee
for the Family Division of Circuit Court
uh the clerk of the house ruled we could
not have a joint meeting so what I've
told the five of us here in the children
and family law work group is remember
everything we said and heard because
we're going to be looking at this very
issue in our special
committee um we heard testimony on this
the other day so just that was uh buying
some time to see if the people to my
right have anything you'd like to share
uh Representatives ball or
McMahon Mr chairman I'll oh microphone I
us I talk too
loud yeah thing I uh have a just in The
Narrative of what brought forth the this
um the particular Bill I'm referring
to uh it's 475 at this point at this
point I is to is to ensure that the
opportunity to provide evidence at the
at the appropriate
time uh is a commitment to respect the
rights of both um both litigants on
either side
and that struck me as well struck me as
just in The Narrative of the bill that
that right would not be as a States
would not be limited to
a uh third party from the two litigants
determining what is an appropriate U
piece of evidence or not and have so
that it would ensure it would be
adjudicated in the discussion and
presentation before the judge and then
the judge can make the decision or or
not can but makes the
decision that's why I thought that's why
in my view I thought that uh in meeting
the challenges we Face based on the
early
the early testimonies that we heard is
the um litigants would have their right
insured to be
heard and I and I wasn't seeing this I
did not see this as infringing on the
authority having jurisdiction which is
the judge says to ensure that the
authority has the evidence to then
determine the
jurisdiction that's what like to offer
that is consideration on 455 475 thank
anything I agree that I think we need to
take a closer look at this through the
special committee
um I do think there has to be an Avenue
for allowing evidence which um we do
have I I think that what we were hearing
or what at least I was hearing in all
the testimony is that people want to be
heard they want an opportunity to
present themselves and I think when that
does not happen um that is when we're
courts
okay in talking with several Family
Court Justices and having sat in on
Nashua Family
Court my experience was that the
judges were quite open to allowing
pieces of evidence to come in except for
a couple
of kinds of
evidences and they're both actually
addressed in the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence book one of these is if the
probative value of the piece of
evidence um is less than any and I'll
use my term now
besmirching of someone's
character um that's not allowed you
don't bring in a piece of evidence
that's basically an attack piece more
than it is anything else secondly um the
judges that I have spoken with are
concerned with somebody just churning
the case and there's a couple of
references in rules of evidence that a
judge should not admit a piece of
evidence if that piece of evidence does
not further the knowledge of the case if
it's repetitive you know he didn't pick
up Billy when he said on Tuesday then
the next piece of evidence is he didn't
do it on Thursday well we've already
established a problem uh because to keep
churning the case like this with
requests for evidence to come in that
doesn't help the case one way or the
other is what wastes time and uh so then
the this begs the question is every
judge observant of those two things I
just said do judges bring in pieces of
evidence where the probative value is
minimal and the sming value is great
does that happen do judges keep letting
one party churn churn churn with more
pieces of evidence and that's where um
you know even if these rules were
followed
are they followed if it says don't do
this and the judge is doing this a Bill
signed into law doesn't actually Advance
anything because they're already
breaking the law you've got
um so therefore the discussion that some
of us have had with the justice
department was there's a couple of
things that we probably need number one
we need better education for the protic
an how many prosay litigants know how
and when you object that a piece of
evidence is allowed in or not allowed in
um we were having a discussion
beforehand that um there are videos you
can watch there are handouts you can
have but the justices I spoke with said
but they can always be made better
bigger Fuller richer
um that may be something we explore in
some greater detail in the special
committee also um the conversation some
of us had was and this goes to the point
about uh that representative Greg made
about uh student teachers being
monitored my suggestion was that the
judges in Family
Division are monitored more frequently
and in particular
if there seems to be numbers of
complaints about that particular
judge um I Heard certain names of Judges
mentioned a lot more during all of our
time of um hearings than I heard other
judges names so maybe there are a few
judges who are way too broad or way too
narrow and once again how can we keep
the wisdom of giving judges
discretion yet re them in or expand them
out or rebalance them if they're
outliers and that I believe is best done
not by a hard fast rule that may
absolutely be the wrong rule to have in
a case across the board but have more
monitoring more continuing ed um any any
thoughts on that representative Greg um
I absolutely agree I had something to
say and then I was like like it went
blank I think my brain froze sorry about
that um you know I did just look up I
Googled super quick like what to do like
for State of New Hampshire if you're
it's all here like I don't even know
that we always run into the problem
though these are emotional cases right
they're the ones that we're seeing over
and over and by the way the judges that
we had mentioned over and over are no
longer judges and that's probably for
good reason but I because the judicial
system kind of has a check and balance
however I do think kind of observing or
having somebody that drops in on courts
from time to time where they don't
necessarily know that they're going to
be there that's that's kind of a better
way to do it the
forms I know that there and that's
something we're going to talk about
later today but I know that they're
working on streamlining them they have
made progress on them but honestly I
went through and I looked at it and of
course I you know I've been to court
with other people and stuff before so I
have a little bit of background
knowledge but it's it really is all here
it's just a a matter of the emotions in
a case whether or not you can slow down
and look at it and read what you're you
know what you're supposed to do there
are videos on here too so I think
that I just want to be mindful of how
many cases we're hearing about versus
how many I don't want to create a bigger
problem because the majority of this is
going
well um how does one access that what's
the Google line well I Googled um New
Hampshire State Court representing
prosay that's all I did and then it
takes you to courts. nh.gov and I've
done it a few different ways I kind of
look you know representing yourself New
Hampshire and it it always brings you to
this and then there it takes you to
self-help and then you got fors and fees
you got videos what to expect your first
day of Court um you know lot preparing
for court there's a whole section here
before your court date what to do on
your court date um even things like
arrive on time I mean that's all on here
you know
to to anyone's
knowledge if you file a
case and then they get back to you and
say your case will be heard on November
14th is there a statement that says and
in your preparation you would be wise to
access because how would somebody not
know they don't know what they don't
know yeah well I do know I uh as
observed and conquered and I do know
they're on the they have the computer
where you can fill out forms and stuff
they actually had a link to come and and
look at this and I do I did hear a clerk
telling somebody too that they could
access it this way I talked to a clerk
and asked you know what they do if
there's a prosay and they do advise them
to go to this but then of course that's
personal choice how much of that you
in
judge mace
um testified before some of us on
specifically Rules of
Evidence and God bless him I uh I got in
touch with him and I said give me some
statement give me a big statement on
what we're concerned about and he is
stuck in traffic trying to get off the
cape so he dictated it to a staffer over
the phone who typed it out and then it
was sent to me and then then to us um
but he
uh he covers three areas one
is what I think we've been saying up
here that we really do want to keep our
judges uh free to apply Rules of
Evidence as they see fit because every
case is different
and he even mentions Vermont where that
is not the case and how much difficulty
it has for people who are not lawyers to
wend their way through the system where
all of a sudden you know pick a rule the
other party has done
homework and you haven't because you
didn't know you don't own this book
amazingly um and so now you're caught
flat-footed and how is that fair and the
judge is not supposed to be the lawyer
you know so we uh spon is not a good uh
legal action so how do you know you
don't know the judge can't tell you well
you should have brought this up so he
said that first in other words tweak
what we've got rather than replicating
what he believes isn't working in
Vermont but then he also added a section
on even more uh narrative and videos and
handouts than we have presently and even
louder uh hey look this stuff up for
folks if you're going prosay and then he
also said the Chief
Justice Mr chairman is very supportive
of your idea about reviewing judges more
frequently particularly with the
assistance of retired judges we would be
happy to talk with you about how um this
can be done so I think there is a
willingness on the part of the Judiciary
to recognize they may have a judge who's
too broad or too narrow or who is
imbalanced um it doesn't rise to the
level of this is a bad judge and and yes
representative Greg there are names that
were mentioned who we just don't see on
the bench anymore these are good judges
let's say who do need some
inservice um continuing education on how
to come back into a better
Norm okay I've just basically said my
opening statement in other words all
over again
anything else from us up here before we
go to particular bills themselves yeah
uh I recall I believe it was Judge uh
lamir was it or lame lamir lamir um who
said There are some evidence that I'm
not considering because for example if
somebody badly characterizes the other
party and the judge isn't buying it
she's not looking for evidence to defend
yourself so I'm going to say no and I
could see a party getting upset saying
hey wait a minute this is you know so I
don't know if the judges could tell uh
could say at that moment that um yeah as
far as your character assassination uh
I'm not considering that I I you know I
don't believe that or whatever uh the
judge would say so that would because I
know if somebody characteriz uh badly
characterized me and I went to put into
evidence to support my character and the
judge wouldn't allow it I'd be upset
because I'd be assuming that she's
buying the other party's uh bad
characterization of me so that was
another thing I was thinking of is of
those that were calling on were calling
upon um you know ween allowed to give
evidence um were they assuming that the
judge was buying the opposition uh you
know they're the other parties uh
whatever the other party said so I don't
know if a judge can say you know that's
not in question your character is not in
question to me for me um so I'm not
going to take evidence supporting your
character because it's not what I'm
considering right now uh representative
Greg you have a judge in the family and
I'm sure this sort of thing has come up
once or twice I do have a judge in the
family and you know I've grilled him on
certain things but also I used to watch
him in court I do know just from I'd
like to I he was not here he's in
Illinois so I like to focus on what
we've got on going on in the New
Hampshire courts but the judge that we
observed did say you know when they
weren't going to allow evidence like
this is why like she was very good about
explaining why or what I will say also
it at courts. new hampshire. goov you
can also just Google Rules of Evidence
and they have it so you can just put in
a keyword so say you want to talk about
stalking say you want to talk about
something else um you can put that in
there and see about the Rules of
Evidence there are cases where
especially in cases of domestic violence
domestic abuse um there are certain
things that is there's a big push that
you see that they want to have brought
in like maybe um the aggressor might
want to have the mental health history
brought up or something like that and so
that's things that we're generally
seeing that no you can't I know one of
um somebody that's testified here and
shared some of their work that was you
know kind of something they wanted to
those are things that can't be brought
up and I do hear the judge saying that's
not admissible you know because we can't
bring up this or whatever so I do I do
think there's that and and I want to be
cognizant that everybody that says hey
they're not listening to me that's
exactly the perception that's your
reality and stuff we've had people come
in here before that I thought man that
person was so aggressive I can't believe
that and then I went back and watched
the YouTube and I was like okay maybe
that was my own bias hearing that a
little differently but it's hard to come
out of that and really watch and see
what's happening because these are high
you know High emotional I mean these are
very important cases and everybody's
evidence is very important but once
again you know there there are ways to
look up Rules of Evidence without having
that book that you actually don't have
to read through the entire thing you
just put a keyword in and see what what
those rules are for that particular
thing it might be helpful the last two
lines of House Bill
475 which is if evidence or testimony is
not
admitted or we could even say is
admitted over the objection of a
litigant that the reason should be noted
that might be helpful to diffuse some
people thinking the judge is biased
against me I'm just you know throwing
that out as a
possibility um I did watch a moot court
trial um
where the litigant was bringing suit and
against the respondent for breach of
contract and the litigant
wanted to exclude the
respondent from describing in her own
words things but instead stick only to
the contract that was allegedly
breached and in one moot Court rendering
of this the litigant said I would like
to give three examples of how this
person cannot be
trusted and the judge said the probative
value of that is exceeded by this again
my word the bment of character in
another rendering of the same moot court
case the um litigant bringing suit said
your honor for the purpose of this I
wish to bring in a piece of evidence
where
unemployment
appeal indicated by the person presiding
that the individual wanting unemployment
payouts uh was self-contradictory
the judge allowed that because it didn't
besmer character but oral testimony
could be impeached by the track record
of the person in a similar thing I'm
going to go to law school darn it you
know I'm really getting into this uh so
there's an example where I never knew
that until I watched this I never knew
that until I read this book four times
and if the judge simply said no I'm not
admitting it I'd want to know why so
maybe there is something to
suggest in our special committee
judges should the reason be noted in the
record or not I'm just throwing that out
possibility uh yeah I could agree with
that uh as long as a judge doesn't have
to review the test
the
evidence
um you know the example that I gave of
uh you know the judge saying yeah I
don't want that evidence of of your good
character because that's not I'm not
weighing in on that I think you have I
think you're of good character so that's
not an issue U that I could note I
didn't re receive evidence on character
because that wasn't uh that wasn't an
issue in my in my judgment um but you
know as long as that as long as a judge
doesn't have to review the evidence or
testimony um which if for any reason
evidence or testimony is not admitted
the reason shall be noted in the record
so you like lines eight and nine of
Representative posts Bill 475 yeah the
the actually the amendment uh the
amendment yes did we weigh in on the
amendment in
recall we rain
that so but yeah I'm I like the
amendment much better the words at the
end of the amendment is much better uh
than the original but the difficulty
about the amendment to 475 starts on
line six the presiding judge Etc shall
follow the New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence when admitting such evidence
and testimony so to me that's not good
for reasons we've been discussing but
what follows is good in my
opinion yeah I I was just specifying uh
line eight and nine if we somehow could
extract line eight and nine in what we
do in special committee into our
recommendations and that could be a
point of further discussion I mean the
Judiciary is really really indicating
they want to work with us on this you
know they they see that there's a
concern and and they want to uh
alleviate it yes representative
ball thank you chairman parison I guess
I just needed a little clarification uh
representative Greg maybe I'm not sure
if I misheard you um you said the
aggressor wants a wants a mental health
evaluation I'm not exactly sure what
to um this is so on a specific case but
we'll keep it um confidential but anyway
um
and this and I've seen it multiple
multiple times but if you have an abuse
let's say an abuser not just aggressor
but one of the things that happens is
you have you might have the uh victim or
the Survivor uh has been to some kind of
like psychiatric help That's Not Unusual
right because they go through depression
they go through denial of you know kind
of the mental and the emotional stuff
that comes with that so there's
something there like you know they're
trying to kind of deal with life well an
aggressor will use that as a weapon to
say they're unstable they shouldn't have
the kids because they've been to this
mental health they don't even
necessarily know what's in there but
it's another way to weaponize that
system to put that person in a more
vulnerable position because obviously
you talk to um you know a counselor or
something about
very uh private details right and
sometimes maybe you've talked about your
abuse sometimes you talked about other
things but to then say you know what I'm
going to the person other person say I'm
G to I want this as evidence I want all
these records opened up and I wanted in
there it's a further abuse and it's a
further manipulation of the situation is
what it
is so I guess that's where my confusion
is because from the people that we were
hearing from there were cases where the
person who filed the DV complaint was
actually the aggressor and
um
so and they were using the court to
weaponize Yes um and that's where I get
concerned so how does a person who's now
been accused of DV how do they fight
that especially when it starts coming
into child custody and temporary orders
and how do they bring forward evidence
to say that maybe the person who
actually filed the DV does have mental
illness and this is part of their mental
illness to bring forward um this type of
retaliation or aggressive behavior
toward who is actually the victim um
who's being accused so I I
I think that's where I'm I'm just
concerned when evidence is not allowed
to show that the person who's being
accused has actually been the
victim well I think that if you have so
if you have a victim saying you know
what I'd like to fet it all out I'd like
to show you to prove my own you know
that I'm not like this or that's a
little bit different than somebody
coming up and saying Hey I want you to
do this I mean there that's the and
that's that's one of these situations
that's really hard and I think that's
when we talk about in our committee
we've talked about the training of
judges and stuff to really look at this
because it is a very challenging
situation and it is it is a a
statistical fact that many abusers if
not most will actually say that they've
been abused in some way or another and
that's their perception they didn't get
their way they didn't get anything else
so it is a challenge but these are the
types of evidences that you're seeing
seeing you know this it's kind of a
hearsay or it's a breach of HIPPA or
anything else that they're wanting to
have this evidence in and that just you
know that has to be up to the judge's
discretion and stuff and I I get your
point that so somebody's been accused it
is hard to prove one way or the other
but there are Avenues you know within
the rules of evidence that you can
actually um do that but it's a matter of
being able to you know kind of look that
up and see that there are some things
you know text messages like text me
those can be admitted you know if you
have the actual not it has to have like
the full text message you know that kind
of stuff can be admitted um if you have
let's say a voicemail from that person
that can usually be admitted something
like that but there are there are
sometimes some kind of patterns but it
can be very challenging in a lot of
cases um people if they can will submit
to you know either psychological tests
of both parties or personality tests or
whatever so it is a challenge but it's
also not the the norm it's not the major
cases character evidence is Rule
404 and having read through not only the
the uh law but the reporter's notes
which gives commentary on case law which
is the second level of law um it's it's
very nuanced to say the least um to be
admissible under evidentiary rule
governing character evidence two
requirements must be satisi satisfied
profit evidence must be pertinent that
is to say it is relevant to this case it
must constitute a character trait but
then there are other times when just
because somebody stole in the past
doesn't necessarily mean they stole this
time and it's you know past sexual
behavior for example is generally not
admissible to prove a particular thing
but sometimes it is so that's why on
some
cases prosay may not be the way to go
yeah that's I mean that's Mike sorry
that is that is the Dilemma of course
and and that's why we do see that
certain advocacy groups and stuff will
provide legal representation or there's
you know other ways to do that because
these These are incredibly complicated
and it it's your life on the line it's
one of those situations where you know
to have people that are actually trained
in this that have gone to school for
this is is the best option um there are
advocacy grp group for that um and some
people can afford it and they choose not
to do it anyway so it's it's a
dilemma yes
representative thank you Mr chairman uh
so
I I mean my concern I mean we're hearing
about the
um uh domestic violence that has
actually happened it's the false claims
as representative ball says uh that's of
concern because now it's your it's your
children and I think
given a reason uh given a reason has to
not let in some character uh positive
information um you know give a reason
and then the judge would have to give a
reason especially if they found that
um there was a potential for domestic
violence you know um you know and that's
the issue and and uh I don't know and
the must of violence is it an automatic
uh criminal case or they could just be
litigated court and
it's okay so would a family would a
family court say that yes we believe
there's been domestic violence they'll
they'll make that statement they could
they could representative katab and I
have a meeting with the speaker later
this week about a bill she's filed where
domestic violence cases should go
because I've heard uh
conflicting desires that is
automatically they should go to u a
criminal court or because they're
interwoven with a family court issue
they should stay so um that's something
that I think some further discussion is
going to ensue when representative kab's
Bill progresses through yes please so
many times those two I've heard a lot of
discussion in domestic violence by the
way these the domestic abuse violence
that's kind of um an undercurrent of a
lot of what we've been seeing and stuff
but on those domestic violence cases you
know whether or not it should be you
know handled in the family courts
whether or not should be criminal there
are times when there'll be a finding of
abuse but the level is not that it's
going to push to criminal or maybe it
was the first time or whatever um those
are constantly interwoven and sometimes
in the family courts something gets
missed that then when the criminal hits
they go back and revisit you know
visitation or whatever else but it is it
is challenging I could speak from
personal experience it is challenging
when you're looking at waiting for
investigations to happen for the courts
but for the family court what they can
say is they can look at like DCFS or
whatever there'll be investigations
there can just be a finding there they
turn in the recommendation to the
authorities on charges that then have a
different perance of evidence but on
that first one for the family courts
when you're looking at the immediate
safety it's much quicker for uh just to
say that there was a finding and those
are investigated and can those be turned
around absolutely but they are done by
experts and they're looked at but it is
important to have the distinction
between the two courts and it's
important to have them in both
ball in the case that I observed
um with a DV case involved the judge was
not taking into to consider evidence
unless it was brought up by the person
who is making allegations so it wasn't
so easy to just put in text messages or
anything um there was no evidence being
accepted my concern is that when you're
accused of DV there is no way um to
defend yourself if they can't get the
evidence in or if they can't question
the mental health of the person making
the
allegation um so I I'm just worried it
with the bill that there it I just
believe it needs to a little bit more
work I think that there needs to be some
caveats um if there is DV involved I
think that there has to be allowed to
have evidence brought in um people have
the right to defend themselves against
these are only
allegations and from what I'm hearing
when police are called to the house
somebody's getting arrested they don't
investigate it there they just make an
arrest and that is the way it is
happening these days and I I think think
it's difficult
um you say that there's help in the
courts there is lots of help in the
courts for the person that's going in
and claiming domestic violence but I
don't see help in the courts for people
who are accused of it there's no one to
walk them through the system to figure
out how to defend themselves they're
often forced out of their houses they
lose all their money they lose access to
their children and they need help and I
think that comes down to the fors it
comes down to education but it ALS also
comes down to evidence and they need to
have the right to present and um
evidence in the court so I'm not saying
all evidence has to be but I do think
when it pertains to the domestic
violence um I think it does need to be
allowed to be in the courts does anyone
up here has anyone up here read uh
violence I'm going to take that as a not
no I'm going to take that as a fournos
one yes I think she's still working on
it she's still working and I saw the
original the reason I'm mentioning that
is if we say in general requiring judges
to follow strictly Rules of
Evidence um is wrong in our opinion
might there be a carve out for DV cases
and that would be perhaps the subject of
her
bill
representative long so my question would
be
um if that were the
case would the judge rule on whether
there there was a finding that there was
domestic violence or there was not
does that require this family court
judge to rule on
that I don't
know if it is brought in as evidence and
that evidence then is persuasive to the
judge for the larger question I would
say he is de facto ruling on it unless
it could be
argued that he would have or she would
have made that finding anyway
irrespective I mean it's for that reason
where admissible errors um are not
appealable if it is ascertained that the
verdict would have been the same anyway
um how are we doing over there so are
you talking about one
about
coordinator I'm not quite
uh
but it's certainly something worth
exploring somewhere that if we simply
keep status quo anti in terms of um
Rules of Evidence do not apply in Family
Division there may want to be a separate
DV because that's where
the
possibility of
subconscious bias on the part of a judge
uh might be more likely and I say
subconscious I agree with that chairman
Pearson and I I do feel that that is the
area of the family court that is being
weaponized and that's why we need to
make sure that everyone has equal access
allegations are we ready to start moving
to the two different bills before us um
I'm going to take 475 because we've been
kindly kind of discussing it anyway um
and
we have I don't have 475 in front of me
but I ALS I do have the amendments in
front of
me um
would somebody like to make a motion on
475 so if I may you may um uh the
amendment I
think I correct well actually I was
going to because we're recommended to
the full committee yeah this is a
recommendation so I would I would
recommend to the full committee that um
on Amendment 2023
10168 that beginning line8 and nine be
reviewed by the full committee if for
any reason evidence or testimony is not
admitted the reason shall be noted in
the
record so that's not an
otpa or itl it is a suggestion which is
I don't think so I mean this is a work
group and we're working and if you want
I could bring that motion forward or I
mean I can bring that Amendment for the
full committee to uh or would you want
representative post
to is it the general view of the five of
us that the
lines final bit of line 8 and all of
line nine are are
good but the rest of the
bill
not you don't have the amendment
no okay well here's the amendment we've
been talking about the very end of line
8 and all of line n talking about Judges
giving reasons if they rule a certain
way that's objected to uh the what's
above it is just generally saying they
got to follow the rules of evidence and
that so we have a suggestion on the
floor that we bring our conversation
eight and above no eight and Below yes
we like is that all in favor please nod
yes nod
representa McMahon okay all right I'll
I'll write some language in here to that
effect
um
uh
righty
and uh where can you get a copy of the
amendment well you can if if you very
nicely ask um our committee researcher
Christina could you possibly send us the
amendment for uh just email us again the
amendment on
475 you don't think you have it I have C
is there a copy machine is there a copy
could we copy
it
d116 yeah I
don't okay so
we representative mcmah says no but I
believe there's a copier down the hall
need
uh I don't think I don't know yeah while
you're up I volunteer to get oh okay all
right all right all right all right four
under under um the next bill here 499
there is an amendment 619 but I list it
actually I got read I wrote on mine so I
think it may have been discussed just
probably not uh yeah I wrote on it too
too on the next bill does everybody have
Amendment 619
that
to
e
do you have both amendments do you have
yes
if everybody would up here would please
read over um now four whatever it is the
other one
499 and the
amendment
sh
Avon
calling
okay
for
just
okay representative
long thank you Mr chairman uh so I think
the first uh the first section uh
responded believes will have favorable
to his or her case for the record this
is amendment 619 to House Bill 499 yeah
actually the original um this changes
the statute uh it's 169 C12 not uh the
490 that was in the original
um so that that tells me there are times
when respondents will put in evidence
that's not favorable to
them I don't know if that's ever the
case
um okay and then in section two it
appears that we I I I think it's going
to be
complicated to tell to tell the judge
that you shall admit evidence and then
say if the judge has reason to believe
that appli of rules shall adversely
affect the
case uh he could wave the evidence I
think that I think that becomes more of
a conflict sets up more of a conflict
between litigants because now the judge
because now you shall admit and then
it's saying however if you
believe uh that it'll adversely affect
the
case um in other words you do what we
tell you except when you don't want to
but well exactly I I you know it's it's
not it's not clear to me it it opens up
for more Arguments for more conflict in
my opinion you may remember and I only
remember because I wrote it down judge
headed who was the link from the
Judiciary to us at the time saw sections
one and two to be contradictory to each
other and you agree I agree you
agree and and I think uh we're in the
other Bill we're addressing
um
um noting in the
file um the rationale for not allowing
and I think that's fair yeah in other
words here line 15 the judge May wave
wave the rules of evidence and shall
note in the file the rationale for this
decision is very similar to what we just
saw and what we are going to recommend
to the children and family law committee
whole so what do we think well
uh yeah I representative Greg would you
like to make a motion on uh Amendment
619 H sure I'd like to make a recommend
uh recommend I'd like to make a
recommendation to the um full committee
um uh now do we have to uh do the bill
as
unamended I don't know what to do next
well we're a subcommittee so we're
really a work group so we could pretty
much do what we can do what we want
that's right so we recommend the bill
and the amendment it out firsted
I how about my folks to the right
here we have a motion on the
yes do you like it or you don't like
it
um I'm going to say
okay so and the cheer votes
itl um and so that makes the vote 3-2 we
recommend itl I would be
interested um as to why you would say no
to itl because then you're telling me
you like
this the issue is what are we doing here
in the first place Mr chair and that's
because you have the judges doing
Collective enforcement of what Rules of
Evidence are okay now that being said we
need when I say we need the system
should allow the uh as you have clearly
pointed out the litigants being given
the opportunity to provide their
evidence now that being said now it's
saying what evidence how it's stated and
then adjudicated after it's been
submitted that's why for myself this is
we not recommending this to the
committee to further discuss and this is
what I'm after that is to have more
application discussion on like like the
case here where the the judges it's
going back to what I believe brought us
here in the first place is where judge
the judge is stating on his own on his
or her own whether uh the the rationale
for a decision not to not to follow the
rules of evidence okay now that's taking
place now without it being in Black
letter it it's it's just the the
Ambiance of the environment not the the
statement of how you can expect it to
perform and it it being in the court so
that but that's why it was not for itl I
want us to do something versus not uh on
uh on this effort and that's providing
voice to the to both on both sides but
the judge is still there to have a fair
application of acceptance of of of this
with a with something written uh for
course of rule I guess the reason why I
didn't have any trouble killing the
amendment SL bill is the idea of the
judge giving reasons for decision was
already discussed and agreed to under
499 and that would be um part of what we
recommended going forward uh to the
whole Committee in other words line 15
is fine perfectly fine it pretty much
replicates line nine in the previous
Amendment but did I misunderstand Mr
chairman you said to it both the
amendment and the bill okay now that
being said then it's as you stated
earlier it's moot to use the word in the
right context and I'm saying for like
I'm for what you just stated is that the
case well then where did that reside
because they just said the iil the bill
twice I mean twice meaning the bill
itself where yeah representative long
yeah so so in 475 we asking the judge to
give a reason why evidence wasn't
submitted in 475 the first one we're
we're in agreement with that the first
the first one so so uh 499 uh replicates
that um well actually section um section
one uh the only difference there is
whatever the respondant believes will be
in their in their favor I I don't know
if I would put in any evidence that
would harm me um so I don't know where
we need that
um I you know they want to put in
evidence that is favorable to them so
that's to me a no-brainer I I get that I
you know I don't know why you need that
in language um and and I think it
creates
complications um and creates more of a
conflict down the road so then 80% that
are
minimal conflict that has a potential of
creating more conflict with that 80%
again we're talking about the 10 15% of
conflict uh cases what would you
think if we took House Bill
499 as a vehicle and admitted section
one Roman one and kept Roman
two if the judge has reasons that
applying the Rules of
Evidence shall adversely affect the case
you could have adversely affect the
case by having unnecessary further
amendments I mean further Evidence you
could do it by probative value outweigh
by bmer merching character uh those are
reasons why a judge would say no um this
doesn't Advance the case so if we just
took Romans Roman two the court shall
apply the Rules of Evidence to enhance
the predictable orderly fair and
reliable presentation of evidence I
think that's in the book somewhere if
the judge has reason to believe that
applying the Rules of Evidence should
adversely affect the case the judge May
wave The Rules of Evidence and shall
note in the file the rationale for the
decision
two if we had an amendment if I wrote an
amendment ran it over we all liked it
and it says basically rule two the whole
bill shall be replaced with just rule
two how does that sound yeah I I'm I
have an issue with uh yeah I would have
an issue with that the uh because the
judge could only uh the judge could
only not
admit not allow evidence if it adversely
affects the case so if
somebody smeared my character and I
wanted to submit evidence and the judge
is saying I'm not buying that person
that's smeared evidence on
you um it's not going to affect
adversely affect the case I see but it
doesch your
character right but the judge isn't
buying it okay you know and that would
be um and that would be written down at
the end uh decision why I didn't take
the evidence because the character of
the respond of of the character of the
party uh was not being weighed in they
they're you know I didn't I didn't
accept that the person
was
whatever
us yeah go ahead excuse me for talking
no that's okay with my colleague just
don't use white out on the screen that's
all I ask okay um as a freshman I just
needed some clarification because I'm
again a little bit um confused used
because this is repealing a different
part of the law than 475 they're two
separate issues and I just pulled up the
part that it's actually saying it would
repeal and that's where I was just
trying to get some
clarification um looking at that section
law I I could be wrong here that's why I
was asking for clarification I guess
what I'm looking for is something that
does not take away the
judge's uh
discretion but adds if the judge accepts
a piece of evidence over an objection or
denies a piece of evidence obviously the
person profer it would object the
reasons must be
stated period you like
sound I
yeah yeah well R ball brings up a good
point um I I don't know if
uh
[Music]
um uh was it 499 that changed the
statute 490 to
so I mean we would be looking to get
that
language of
475 if we were going to go with uh
499 I don't know if it needs to go into
169 so what I I'm what I'm reading here
is the the 169c semicolon 12 that
they're talking about
um that they're looking to
repeal
is
what is
499 so they're looking to repeal that in
any hearing under this chapter the court
shall not be bound by the technical
Rules of Evidence and may admit evidence
which considers relevant material
evidence of Prior unfounded or founded
reports of abuse or neglect shall be
admissible in proceedings under this
chapter um to establish re relevant
patterns or course of conduct
I
want
anybody
okay
okay and 409 addresses
all okay
stat so they go to two different places
in the
law if I may yeah thank you Mr chairman
uh so if we put it in 475 IT addresses
all 490d addresses all family court
evidence and
499 changing it to 169c just addresses
uh well you be duplicating it just
addresses abuse and neglect cases
169c
so we already got it all addressed in
475 okay
um then try this out take out the
amendment 1016 to House Bill
um we strike the amendment strikes
everything up until just about the end
of line eight right and what we add or
change it in fact it strikes the whole
thing and the an amendment could say if
a judge chooses to admit evidence or
testimony and one of the litigant
objects or if a judge chooses to deny
profit evidence or
testimony the judge shall note in the
decision that keeps the them free to use
their discretion but if in the admission
or denial of testimony or evidence
somebody objects the judge has to give a
reason just as if a litigant objects the
Lian has to give a
sound yeah I I mean I think the Judge
ought to give a reason no matter what I
do too um so but then it goes in the
record and so if you want to collect
records and say judge
Snodgrass so frequently does such and
such and gives this cockman reason then
somebody could say okay here is a unique
base if you I would think if appeals can
be made on error of law or accepted
process you can't just appeal because
you're lost abuse of
discretion and this might
help so I mean thank you we've already
established that proos don't object
because they don't know they could but
we also now we're saying if they object
so if they make a mistake and don't
placed uh we've already said that we are
going to be talking to the committee as
a of of what do we special committee
that we want to have a conversation with
the Judiciary yeah about all of this
we've already noted that in here so are
are we of agreement that we can take
either one of the bills and got it and
replace it with the sentence I just
read uh I'm happy just the way it is
I'm happy with my itl on 499 and with
the fix in 475 that covers all all how
about you folks over there who were
against this itl I mean we can
reconsider a vote if we think now we we
to oh I'm sorry I was going to say I
make a motion to reconsider the previous
vote okay this is where we run out of I
haven't been a clerk in five years uh
okay re reconsider the vote on
499 is that the
motion yes reconsider the itl reconsider
itl on
by
nickmah
seconded by
McMahon
all right so do you need to be in the
majority to uh yeah if we're going to
reconsider the vote to itl then we can
come back with an a unanimous it we can
come back with the request for an
amendments we can do that we can revote
if this
passes so the motion before us I mean
I'm asking
if a person of the minority could
reconsider a vot
sure
yeah I mean it's a work group so it's a
work group much okay
so the motion is
to reconsider the itl on 499 the chair
votes yes uh representative long
no representative
Greg representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes now we're
reconsidering
is
um that we ex we agree to an
amendment that replaces
619 another amendment and the amendment
reads line one amend the title of the
bill by replacing it with the following
line three an act relative to admission
of certain evidence in Family Court
proceedings line five amend the bill by
replacing section one with the following
line seven child protection act
evidence
um RSA 169 C12 is repealed and reenacted
to read as following and then that is
where the amendment just simply adds um
what I had written earlier what IID read
a judge chooses then must give reasons
decision that just iding that last
sentence on 499 pretty much yeah line 14
15 yep without another word just that St
if the
judge if a judge chooses to admit
evidence or testimony and one of the
litigant objects I could change the word
chooses to rules or
decides uh or if a judge chooses to deny
profit evidence or testimony the judge
shall note in the record reason for this
decision and this is if I may yeah go
ahead uh and this is only on abuse and
neglect
cases
169c okay 169 is abuse and neglect um
misplaced I wanted it to be on anything
before Family Court yeah that would be
49 that would be
four 490 uh whatever it is 47 it's it's
already in
475 um all right right okay so I should
have changed decided to change 475
all right 475 is the broad one yes
family cour it covers the family court
all right thank you for that and by by
stating
that that would include then
DV correct
yeah make on that as well yeah any
Division put it
repeal all right so actually now 499 is
back on the
table and the chair apologizes for the
confusion
okay so now we can go back to our
recommendation
on um
and it's 499 is only on abuse and
neglect I'm repeating that until I
remember
it
so it's putting that last statement into
475 yeah yeah let's just by 499
is better
deleted with 475 being the one bill is
as
am right uh but what was added to uh 499
in your well $ 499 we look looking at
the amendments does it adversely affect
the case is
that was that included in your Amendment
my amendment is now going to be
suggested for 475 yeah and what is that
I'm sorry Amendment what was that
Amendment it's still Jud still on a
yellow
pad oh no but I mean um was it starting
it was 14 and 15 starting at the judge
or did it include adversely affect the
case
your proposed my proposed amendment for
475 and you're on 499 right because
you're taking the bottom of this to take
every everything out of 475 and simply
replace it with if a judge refuses to
admit or does admit and it's subjected
to the judge has got to give reason
noted in the record uh I'm not offering
this now on
499 right and
right because this the 499 is restricted
to abuse and neglect
correct that's would apply to all cases
before Family
Court the amendment judge would have to
give a reason
for the amendment to 475 applies to
everything right four um 499 applies
only to
169 and as we all know from reading the
newspapers the prime sponsor was thick
addresses so let's take these things uh
in order um having put 499 back on the
table uh
reconsider what do we want to do with
499 as it is before
us with the amendment
yes I didn't think we were amending uh
499 I thought we were taking a piece of
475 we
ited
amendment we reconsidered it we now have
to vote we have done legally nothing on
499 and again apologies voted 3 to2 to
reconsider okay so we can go go back and
do
it so on House Bill 499 if I all right
you may make a motion representative to
it all right this is Rev voting which we
gave oursel permission to and that is
representative long and do we have a
Greg now the motion before us is
Amendment right now the motion is 499
without the amendment yeah yeah if we
kill 499 then the amendment is moved
right so the the motion before us is
499 uh I will now call the role and
representative long yes yes um
representative Greg yes representative
McMahon
and representative
ball and
um the chair recommends to kill it so
it's back to where we
were uh and remember these are only
recommendations to the committee of the
whole where we can make our case now um
we never voted on
475 except to say we all and I'm quoting
generally do not favor forcing Judiciary
to abide by Rules of Evidence but we do
want greater materials to prepare prosay
litigant more explanations of how the
Rules of Evidence work during a trial
and monitoring judges more closely
especially those who seem to be in the
extremes for evidence um one way or the
other or we also believe a carve out of
the blanket discretion Rules of Evidence
on domestic violence should be discussed
by the special Committee in judiciary
that's our recommendation
um do you wish to further encourage me
to uh go get an amendment you can walk
down there with me if you want to so we
have one of you know both of us um so
that's my question to you do you like
475 um amend a new amendment that will
be
forthcoming that will read this if a
judge chooses to admit evidence or
testimony and one of the litigant
objects or if a judge chooses to deny
proferred evidence or testimony the
judge shall note in the record the
reason for this decision that amendment
to be worked on by OS will replace the
bill what's your thoughts I think we
kind of like that we like that uh well I
I um
I I think as far as the objection goes
isn't that
current that if a judge jge uh disallows
evidence the litigant could object uh
because if they appeal they need to be
able to bring that to the appeal the
litigant May object at that time and
must give reason for
it right I don't know I don't know if we
need to add the ejection part I mean
give reason for for it I I agreed like
the last sentence in uh the amended
House Bill 475
uh actually starting on uh page eight if
for any reason evidence or testimony is
not admitted the reason shall be noted
record you
know
that I'm sorry anybody with a law degree
go ahead
counselor it's
you
counselor
said
yeah I I mean I haven't heard testimony
from anybody saying um I want to know
why he admitted my testimony no I want
to know why he admitted her
testimony all right I objected in the
yeah now and I gave a reason and I was
denied I want to know why specifically
have So currently they're not required
to give a reason why they're overruling
an
objection they're not required they're
not judges aren't required to give a
reason why they're overruling and
objection are they required I would
so
okay so we are not going to make a
specific uh motion to the committee as a
whole on
475 but we've got a narrative of items
we pretty well agreed to yeah okay yeah
we have two proposed languages right
let's see where the committee
will this is I haven't been clerk in
several years and I'm doing it the way I
did it before pen and
paper very detailed too you can I would
not fill both Sid of a
paper
yeah okay I think we're done folks
and very good thank you and thank you
Council Alyssa and when's the next
meeting one o' one o'clock for some of
us and
um thank you everyone and would you like
to walk down with me to Os
or crafting an amendment that then could
be offered yeah but I'm not an agreement
I'm in agreement with
this okay so so I'll bring this
who